ah this is interesting some friends of
mine just had a baby a man and a woman
had a baby you made made a baby pretty
exciting and I actually asked the fella
how it felt what it was like to be a new
dad hey anyone kind of was like will
Peter I could tell you but there's just
it's just no words there are no words
for it my friend you would never
understand what I'm feeling I could
describe it but I would fail you're just
gonna have to wait for it to happen to
you yeah
ah no I don't just because I don't have
kids doesn't mean I don't know extreme
joy I totally do I mean I may be
childless but I have found an onion ring
hiding in my french fries so second sure
it's not fatherhood but you bet I had
some of the same feelings when I saw
that little guy hiding in the other
rigid ones there's a circle yeah I
wanted to hold it up like symbolic got
to eat that ring can you eat your baby
no so why don't you let me tell you
about joy pal
[Applause]
my point is joy is hiding everywhere not
just in big moments put in little ones
too it's all around you like you ever
pull over to park and of all the open
meters you could have chosen to pump to
park at you choose a meter that already
has time on it
there is a God and He loves us what are
the chances for billion to one I'm not
good at math for billion to one is it
four billion to one I always get out
unlike to the beautiful soul that put in
those extra quarters I thank you waiting
for Jesus to drive by Anna's VW bus
don't mention a Peter or how about
walking into a movie theater you think
it's gonna be crowded and you end up
being the only people in it that is one
of my favorite feelings in the world
that is true joy I'm expecting it to be
sweaty and packed people in tall hats
talking loudly kids shooting spitballs
at the screen was this 1930 I hope it's
a good talkie teenagers everywhere
necking the entire way through Rio - I
have to tell him to stop like hey I came
here to see you and Hathaway is a bird
not to see YouTube's blurring the line
between second and third base no you go
in and it's completely empty in the
theater suddenly I feel like a movie
star billionaire with his own private
screening room it's the best it's like
looks like this viewing of Rio - just
became pants optional here's my point
you don't need something huge to happen
to feel huge levels of joy inappropriate
illogical levels of it are everywhere
you just got to keep your eyes out
like ever discover a cat in a bookstore
on a rainy day you just see him on the
stacks you like you feel like you're in
Harry Potter it's magical
you wouldn't even be surprised if the
cat was like nonfiction is that way
puts on glasses and walks through the
wall demon cat that's gotta be as good
as having a baby right
[Applause]
[Music]